and action welcome to the standalone
wait wait go
because i was laughing man didn't even
get mr second break
now we're back again little hiatus
yeah a little covered hiatus but we're
back again so today we're going to be
talking about
foden and greenwood phil foden and mason
green with the two footballers
everyone i'm sure has heard about what's
happened with them top sugars man
yeah top shaggers but no tactics but
yeah we'll get into you do you
rate it or do you think that before we
get into
obviously my guest today the dream team
back again the usuals
we've got ozio oswald to my left looking
like some any south boy in his man
united top
base south point croydon park you're
there
we got chip ricky over there far left
has gotten longer as you can see looks
good though looking
fresh and then we got a real northerner
elbow over here on my right
as we were saying mason agreement phil
foden
talk to me rick you had something to say
go on i was gonna say
do you rate it
what they done do you rate it because
how old are they 19
oh yeah i don't think there's any
problem what would you because
cause everyone's saying oh no it's their
big chance
but they just played that's what i mean
like
i'm saying whether the press was going
to tear them down now or tear them down
in 10 years or the next tournament or
something
tournament something was gonna happen
and the press was gonna get onto them
everyone has their advices
rooney's vice banging grannies alex
arnold trent alex whatever trend trent
was on pregnant
this is the thing people people forgets
as [ __ ] in football
so quickly if ryan giggs could bag his
sister's wife and then get cheered when
he scores a goal
obviously in terms of what's going on
obviously in terms of what's going on in
the world now
covered in that yeah so that's that made
a difference made a difference that was
wrong
but they were done for that because how
the england team
have have had to move yeah with no one
in nowhere now
and how they've been having to travel
and how they've obviously seen how
strict
it is yeah yeah to bring random
girls do what do you know the jokes
thing about this is yeah because when i
read the story i was like
they just brought things back to their
hotel thinking this in england
but they were in iceland that's what i
thought i thought what they bought these
chickens
in saint george's blog i was like that's
might be some covert operation then i
was like
i said aren't even finding things in
iceland no so obviously
no they were talking to these things
from what they on instagram you ready
yeah oh you're actually in your country
you know yeah greenwood was
sorting out yeah because did you hear it
yeah
that was sick that was sick but like and
the girls obviously were down to go and
obviously whatever they did they went
there
they went they went they went but i'm
just saying do you think that in that
position
two two lads who've i guess they've just
come from like humble backgrounds yeah
they've been given a huge opportunity
fair enough they have you have to grow
up
you're you're 19. bro you can just miss
out one day shag you know
you can just miss it think about
everything in context they're in iceland
it's not even like they're in england
they're like yo just come there's a lot
of lock down you see it's exciting but
you agree with it no i i get that
they're 19 though that is so young yeah
like
they're not greedy because that's why
you should be more shook to do it yeah
yeah but their footballers they can do
it that's what i mean they've been
they've been on a pedestal their whole
life
has got a bird and a two-year-old yeah
at home
so that's has she left him
she stayed with him she won't do it he
probably just said nothing happened
you saw that tweet though yeah is this
is it the part when you flash up the
tweet
okay what did you
all right so random not going to say his
name
well well well phil foden's girlfriend
forgives him for taking a girl back to
his hotel room
emoji emoji shocked face looking up eyes
like we knew this was gonna happen
i suppose it was either that or she'd
have to get a [ __ ]
job yeah but i this is right
this is why that's rude and that's good
because you don't know because
you don't know if if them two have been
together since before he was a baller
number one yeah
but he's he's been in an academy since
he was like bro
there's about 7 000 kids yeah in and out
of academies each year
and like one will make it to pro one
will sign a contract in it
i think phil foreign has been man city's
like golden boy for time yeah
at the end of the day maybe she's
thinking because
i think we gotta think as well that
these boys ain't on
no small money no no she's thinking you
know what and she's not married to him
yet even though they've had a kid yeah
if they break up all the money's going
to the kid right
yes so she don't want to [ __ ] up her bag
like she's 19.
i guess you want to [ __ ] up her back
maybe you should let one slide
we don't even know what you've done
listen bigger footballers
have got away with worse on that as well
yeah see i
i just what i actually think i actually
think yeah
see the senior players are moving like
that
no this is what i was gonna say but you
should know about this yeah because the
senior players are so
patterned and how they move with their
women
or whatever in their mistresses it's so
patented you see how rappers
get get women to science nda's yes
yes and so you actually can't you can't
post about it because you're getting
sued
yeah yeah exactly that's why you can't
read them but
but they have
yeah yeah i've got bridges i've gone to
footballers houses like whether it's
been after a festival after a club
and as soon as they got to the door his
phone's in lockers yeah
it's nba's obviously these men didn't
would die
they weren't do you know what i mean and
they're learning though they're 19 that
they're still going to do this let's not
let's be honest but they're going to be
as you said they're going to their
skills are going to go up and they're
going to do it
is this going to hinder their england
career no and you know what even if i
was them i wouldn't give free [ __ ]
because england
ain't the end there will be old man be a
[ __ ] legend for your club your club
the ones paying you more of you most of
your money that's what you're gonna miss
your endorsements
sure what what what fun england
remembered for for for england over
their club
that's because we ain't done [ __ ] though
bobby morrison
yeah but and the way the way the way
and then the way the way is like goes on
anyway we only care about international
football every four years anyway
in between every two years anyway
exactly and like you said everyone has a
short memory
yeah no much is that [ __ ] yeah how are
you not feeling about football with no
family but wait wait wait wait before
before before we digress here
what do you think about people telling
telling sex stories when it's your
business as much as theirs
so this so this has been happening from
day
like you all know like remember when we
were younger you go pick up news of the
world every week a footballer was
getting back
paid freak but obviously they were
getting money in it and then we found
out that
the papers were bugging cars phones
ready that's how they were finding out
all this information but not really
people
yeah that's what i mean and then
obviously they were going to the girls
the girls were like you know what we'll
give you money then the girls are
spilling whatever doing the photo shoot
and then that died it's gone quiet for a
bit and then this year
something i don't know what it is
everyone's just telling everyone's
telling
and i don't know if we can go into this
because we are
still here that um
you see those chicks who went viral
saying that they get one girl said she
gave head to the whole
huh you know their names the whole
basketball team
you know their name bro tell us their
names what's their names it's
news brother you can tell us their names
freaking
cause now she said she she said a story
couple months ago she said she gave me
seven man
whatever and then aussies is up
but then all right have you returned to
watch her podcast again since to see if
she's going to drop more stories
no i don't watch it you know her name
bro you know her name
and then they've done the same thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah so
but then see the girl i said the first
video started yeah the first video she
was just a guest now
she's a host alongside because it blew
up so much what she said
and now they bring it next yeah and
they're all dropping stories
now their whole thing the whole podcast
is to bring in other girls yeah to talk
about
um yeah and you're right it would be
good to have a girl here because let me
ask you all
is it women in power if you had sex with
a celebrity
would you tell the papers no no no done
how much money though these girls
getting paid no
you tell you tell you tell probably a
small circle of friends like you know
no let's be real you're telling your
friends bro i mean publicly
you know you wouldn't but obviously like
i said i don't know if we can speak on
this too much because
like we haven't got go here like whether
it's female empowerment what not
whatever
he was saying like oh jada likes it in
the bottom
not and now
i've seen better articles where the
girls are like i shouldn't have done it
well of course you shouldn't
like white things like white so
basically did the girl do it because she
wanted the fame
like i just wanted to come after did she
want the come up did she want everyone
going to her insta now look here bro her
insert is probably
five times but then maybe i don't know
maybe
like did my man tell her from the start
like listen we're just gonna do a thing
and we're never gonna be together like
or because if you had a foot you might
be with this person
you wouldn't expose everything would you
but they don't you're talking
no one thinks they're going to be with
them bro some people
do you know there's some that's why
that's why they can get away with it
in iceland
people's even banging rappers in
backstage [ __ ] where you think they go
they've got a chance of
getting a ring you gotta respect the
hustle though yeah but it's not a hustle
that's not so bad why some of it some of
it is a hustler
right and then how well you
these rappers are whapping ten things
a week yeah and you'll hear one story
here and there so really
the nine teams are getting whacked where
how are they getting
any profit or any clout already maybe
maybe maybe because maybe they're
signing contracts
and they're just doing their thing
because
the fans of the artist or whatever but
then but then but then those other ones
but then those girls are dependent on
the eyes now
oh i see you doing nothing bro that's
what i mean
some women might be kept you know i mean
if something
a fool who's that the king of ladies you
see chris brown you think
chris you think chris brown yeah briss
breezy yeah that's what academic schools
in here
the king of the light skin guys yeah the
king
the leader the leader from dave from
when he was in school you think he
needs to give out gifts to yell you will
want to give him
are you dumb you will do bro
if like his manager or one of his boys
yeah put on his story saying
yo and we have we're having a a party at
chris brown's house
only come if you're down to what to do
you know what our eyes eyes eyes
200 girls are queuing up around the
corner
200 girls they're coming 200 girls 200
percent are coming but what i'm saying
is
there's some girls that these guys are
beating that
they want to keep people at champions
league levels yes and they don't want to
[ __ ] up what they have at home so
they're like listen
i'm gonna give you a little maybe five
grand a month
or i'm gonna pay you a rent exactly look
at drake to keep
quiet and they'll do that he pays my
rent
all right think about that one thing
about drake how many people have had to
use smash bros
and no one has said to you not one
person yeah
bro couple things he's got a lyric
which is that that he falls asleep in
sororities and no one takes a picture of
him no one films him
the sleeping stories of just bear things
around him poised that's what i mean
and i'm sure like 70 80 percent of these
footballers
are [ __ ] that's how they moved yeah
yeah foden and greenwood will learn
isn't it
you have the dog level of being a man
but
you've got things throwing themselves at
you so you have to be a next level of
man to just be loud
i'm not touching i'm not you know what i
mean what would you do with temptation
yeah there's there is there are some men
that are stronger than that but
no lebron's doing the thing but he's
paying yeah like
even david becker has been puppy yeah
no it hasn't won one has slipped bob you
don't yeah
dave beckham's being whapping what david
beckham yeah wow he's a good family man
good friend
he's probably getting like eva longoria
furrowing himself at him and [ __ ] but
he's a man
at the end of the day these guys will
learn [ __ ] it
they just they don't do it have you ever
have you ever heard in your in your
in your tabloid life of it being the
other way around
oh i've met men telling stories or
anyone men telling stories about
women men telling stories about women i
guess tumblers don't really care about
that too much
no they don't because i feel like i
don't think like
celebrity women are going around just
popping random [ __ ] lives but it
wouldn't but
like one like here and there you you
like that
i feel like i feel like these celebrity
women always seem to wifey these random
guys
and we're like who why you know what i
mean
because they want to know just a random
business yeah i feel like
the women always seem to wife for these
guys because they're they're
sick of this they know what men in their
field are like
so actresses are not gonna ever actor
because they're like you managers
working
sports exactly so yeah
yeah i don't think i've ever
i guess it's men with money in it yeah i
always go by the [ __ ] the phase that
monogamy is a poor man's game
so now are we gonna are we gonna say
that what's the comment the comment did
you see the comment on the tweet
the comment on the tweet where the guy
goes oh yeah
these women heal like wolverine when
when the when the when the money's right
ouch elaborate don't just elaborate come
on man elaborate
from what okay cool if you look at this
from distance right right if you go
all the money what you got 10 million
your wife ain't even if you [ __ ]
[ __ ] another [ __ ] simple but if she
can't afford to keep the lifestyle by
herself she's going to stay with you
yeah and yeah
no that's unless she can get something
from it unless she's got a plan
to marry me and then get something from
it she's not leaving you
highly unlikely you've accustomed her to
a different lifestyle i know what she's
going to leave you because he said
something i agree
we're not talking about it i think i
think i think it's all relative i think
yeah
if say uh you've got with someone like
your child
your childhood sweetheart and you've
become famous and rich early and you've
stayed together for years
and her and so so she's never even had
to get a job because you're like
i'm you you're good i've got you you're
going to be a stay at home
but you let me see you're going together
but she's never had to go out and do
anything you know what i mean we're not
saying names
we're not saying names because i don't
know i don't even know an example
yeah we do have an example i don't want
to say names because this man's wife is
quite quick to
take people to court anyway
yeah yeah true true but anyway um
and they grow together and then if she
what if she if she wants to leave and
then you're right yeah
it's different now because because if
she's nearly 30 or 35 and she's like
what the f what am i going to do so it
is different
but i wouldn't i wouldn't say every
woman i wouldn't say i i i would think
that's a majority
but i'd not say the majority i would
save the jury the other way around
no no then because these
do you think because you think yeah how
you're talking is like
the men don't even know that they're
they're being dogs and they're playing
dirty
they want to be with their wife bro no
they do but you can't have both in there
so so the maps are not going to be like
flipping all right and if you want to
cut like i'm good because i've got the
money now
it definitely doesn't work like that but
i think they say you can do
then they regret it's different for
every
yeah at the end of the day just be loyal
people no of course just be loyal
black men don't cheat anyway just leave
the stressors
but it's not black men don't cheat bro
black men don't cheat elbow i don't know
about you
but listen foden greenwood you mum want
your stranger danger
and to do your thing before you settle
down
you know what i mean just be better
cleverer
bro if i'm not your nda's get your
[ __ ] lockers at the door
if i'm 90 i'm whacking everything yeah
but i'm saying they've got a pattern
but
do they want their business every day
[ __ ] but do they want their business
people
are so boring bro we need mavericks
that's why we love people like
like banatelli and adriano and mutu and
all these guys because we've been like
oh my god they're so sick they're
they're mavericks they're just normal
brothers these men are so boring bro
yeah
i know brothers you've got a lovely life
bro if you train you train
you train from 10 a.m to 1 00 p.m
get a little rough every day you get a
rub down by three you're finished that's
your job done you got the whole day
and then you play on a saturday doesn't
see what you're saying
they're the most boring brothers in the
world i know so many footballers
personally but
that might not they might not wash them
they're so boring for them
they need to be in it be a rock star be
like 80s
be a rock star but
they don't need their [ __ ] out there
every day if it's coming every once in a
while cool but if they're beating five
days a week and there's a new girl
hotting them up
every day it's gonna get tiring though
yeah the media will get bored of it get
bored of it
yeah because obviously and then did you
see the video of brewster running
along with tom davis yeah what did she
look like what does she look like
i'm just saying whoever runs in england
just
from a fat sex party for these man let
them
get it out [ __ ] insists
yeah but that's that's that's what
footballers are on bro yeah but so yeah
whoever genuinely
is always there there are women in the
evening that's why he's tapped
and they all had to put their [ __ ]
thing in them
in a bag yeah the tourist security
couple for glue
i'm just saying honestly these men are
all horny in it
yeah they're human just throw a fact in
for them be like look
here's your little yeah i'm from sex
probably
when they had their shared birthday they
said they hired out a building
there was a floor for everyone with
their wife that wanted to come with
their wives and there was a flaws fool a
floor called a single man to just go
and be single do you know what i mean
and that one was the floor with no
phones nothing
that's on phd when they heard that yeah
who's to the joint fighter i think i
think icardi neymar
and maria had a joint birthday party and
they had a floor for every man that had
their
wifey and girlfriend and the floor for
the singles yeah those are the kids the
kids on there yeah
you know what i mean so you just gotta
be smarter with it
no i just think yeah well sex is a weird
taboo bro
yeah because everyone loves it
everyone's yeah and it's
everyone does it yeah it's just like
it's bare rattling to talk about
which is so i'm kind of contradicting
myself because you shouldn't really talk
people's business anyway
yeah yeah but that's what i mean but
sex is a like front page story of a
footballer
of of carl walker that was
because he broke yeah it is that's what
i mean yeah when you're breaking laws
when you're cheating these stories have
been going for time any football that
does it out
outside of the year so but just just to
be clear we're not we're not we're not
full
breaking we're not breaking the law
we're not for breaking the thought
or cheating on families and [ __ ] but
beat well
before yeah beat do your thing if you're
free and out there
but but we can all agree what their man
done
wasn't that it was no it was stupid it
was best it was stupid but
it was kind of funny the phone calls
yeah it was oh yeah it was fun they got
back differently it was fun mason
greenwood
but the girls like videoing in that that
was loose
yeah yeah they were young and you know
they've got gas footballers on them
everyone gets
excited you know i guess they're first
princesses here
so here's what it is but yeah so i think
yeah we'll conclude that and so what's
the conclusion round that up
in a sentence you want me to run that
round for me
i just feel just be smart no that's dude
that's the conclusion brother they just
gotta be smarter with their game brother
that's
it but they'll learn that they should
crack on but not uncovered
yeah not incoming be responsible if you
haven't misses unless you've agreed it
don't do it
unless you've agreed that's what i've
agreed with open open relationship
some people got that they actually don't
exist man
i think i think it takes a certain level
of man it takes a certain level of
matter
that's them cockhold videos that you're
watching
the white men watching their girls it
takes yeah it takes it takes a certain
level of man and girl to be
happy with an openness yes it's trash
at one point someone's gonna get jealous
yeah
all right that's so and that's it so so
that's it stand out tv podcast we'll be
back soon
bye from myself aj boogie bye from
aussie oh
cheap head rickster over here the real
northerner elbow until next time catch
us on standout tv
follow us on the standout tv instagram
standout tv youtube
follow and subscribe bang bang
one more for all your popcorn needs
chopped b-1 chop b-1
you gotta keep that you gotta keep that
for joey's got that tell me what
chubby one you gotta chop me one no you
gotta keep that keep throwing one
popcorn passion please lovely gourmet
popcorn
it's vegan is popcorn vegan it's cool
it's vegan but the flavoring
the flavoring so we've got lovely
flavors here we've got
raspbian white chocolate with coconut
got vanilla marshmallow which is percy
my favorite get little chunks of
marshmallows
but yeah yeah it's gonna be at the end